for me but so i am what they call
empathic and i didn't understand this at
the time
i feel people's energy so especially
when i start to connect with a soul
they'll make me feel the bond that they
shared with someone but then they'll
make me feel how they died
so if they die tragically i'll taste
blood sometimes it's all like if someone
had an aneurysm or they had a bleed out
um if they couldn't communicate if they
had a tube down their throat i'll feel
like someone's restricting my throat
and it's just for like a split second
but i learned to understand what that
was so imagine feeling all of those
things and not knowing what it was
and i was afraid of everything i
couldn't leave my house at this point
i believe that each and every one of us
has the power within ourselves
to create the life that we really want
and i want to help give you the tools to
make that happen
i'm danica patrick and i'm pretty
intense
today on the show oh my gosh it's so
exciting for me
i love talking to people that
tap into energy and spirit
and the quantum field and so i'm super
excited to have teresa caputo
on the show today she is the long island
medium
which comes back out again it's been
going on for 10 years
so if that doesn't say how much everyone
else loves talking to spirit and hearing
from spirit
nothing else does on discovery plus
february 5th
she also has her hay spirit podcast
which i
did um not long ago and it was so
fascinating i mean just to just to to
speak to someone who's able to access a
field of information
that is not in most of our grasps right
now
but is possible for all of us is it's
like it's like talking to an oracle it's
like
you just it's such a fascinating realm
to me and i think
uh you know i love that it exposes this
other
aspect to existence that we all
feel a little curious or skeptical or
maybe not believe at
all um which is this this sort of
quantum field the spirit field this
energy it's the stuff we can't see
i hope that by the end of this
conversation
you feel a deeper connection
to this energy that is always trying to
communicate with us
and that you use it for good to be
happier
and to connect so enjoy the show how are
you
i am fantastic how are you yeah i'm good
i you know i was thinking about um the
last time
we talked because i was on your show and
um you're talking about how you prepare
for someone coming on the show and um
you kind of go into meditation and and
get maybe you could define what that is
that you actually do before you
interview
but do you do that if you're doing an
interview or are you like
blank slate does things accidentally
come in like how does it go
well i always meditate uh every morning
um
i did a little quick prep because i had
some things to do
before this so i had done it earlier but
it's
it's interesting because as you started
talking i felt myself i was like
wait a minute should i be protecting
myself like should i be getting ready
for something i don't know
but it was just like instinctively it's
almost like sometimes i think
now with especially with zoom because
this is how we did do
a whole almost a whole season of long
island medium on zoom
i just immediately just protect myself
in god's white light and just always ask
for the highest good of all concerns so
oh so it's more of a protection
meditation or prayer than it is
a tapping in yes so what i do
is uh like i said i have a meditation
routine that i do every day i only
meditate 10 minutes at a time
that's all i'm able to do at this time
to really get a
full benefit of meditation um and it
took me a while to get there
but for years my meditation
um i always say the ah father and i
always
imagine um god's white light coming in
through the top of my head
pushing out any gray negativity uh from
my body
and just like i almost imagine myself
like translucent
and then i imagine everything drained
from me being trans
trans transformed into magnificent white
light and then i imagine it like coming
up through my
feet through my tailbone and just
encasing me in god's white light and
then i imagine it's showering me
with god's white light protection and
all information for the highest good of
all concerned
what do you think is actually happening
and why do you believe
what is going on and why do you believe
it works
i believe that it works for several
reasons i've done this since day one
since i discovered my gift
and because i only wanted things to help
people and
i'm afraid of my own shadow i only
wanted good things and to be able to
help people
i know i'm afraid of the dark danica
please you have to talk about this
but i but i talk to dead people yeah you
do all these crazy things right
and you're afraid of the dark there's
just something that's so because i feel
like
when i sense and feel the souls are
departed i see them
differently but when it's pitch black
for some reason it's extremely scary for
me
because i can almost see like in the
light i can see silhouettes or
shadows and when it's dark i can't
so for me that's frightening yeah
so when i i believe um and i know i i
share this with people not
only for information because they're
curious because of what i do
that i i always share that i am a
practicing catholic
um there are a lot of things that with
my faith that i don't
agree with so i just don't i pay no mind
you know i just take from but it's like
anything i do in my life
i take every moment for what it is
i take the positive benefits for me
and everything else i let go of anything
that doesn't serve me a purpose
i kind of let go of and
i know that i was blessed with this gift
because
i was born this way i don't know any
different from the age of four
i would say to my mom i feel different
than everyone else i feel like i don't
belong here
and my mom would literally say to me i
remember her saying to me one day
listen stop saying that you don't belong
here you belong here you're part of this
family you're not adopted
you know because if i was adopted you
could at least understand that emotion
right
or that feeling but there was no real
reason
and i love sharing that part of my life
with people because
i think in every way shape or form we
feel
different well
i i think that sometimes yeah i think
but we have to define that
of of who we are different or like we
might not fit in or we do things
differently
for you for example race car driver yeah
right
how many women you know right
and i used to say i don't think my
parents when they held me for the first
time
said oh nick i hope our daughter grows
up talking to dead people
yeah like that's not normal it's like
not even in the category of
and i even feel like for you right it
wouldn't even be like oh i hope our
daughter
grows up to be a race car driver you
want to be a nurse
a doctor a teacher right a a
cosmetology school an electrician
police officer right like these are
things that people inspire to grow up to
be
and i think when you feel like you're
something different or you want to be
something different that
quote unquote isn't normal but the
reason why i share this is because i
feel like
we are responsible for finding our
normal who says
who defined what normal is because for
me talking to dead people is
normal i i i felt complete when i
embraced my gift
you know i was 28
when i found out that not only was i
sensing and feeling my own loved ones
but everyone else is
here i was my my ex-husband had survived
a brain tumor
two beautiful children still having my
grandparents
my parents i had every blessing that
life had to offer
and it wasn't until i embraced my gift
is when my soul
felt complete that's such like a
fascinating aspect to get into because
it's really about
to me what i'm hearing is alignment
right like alignment with the
soul um so
like what kept happening to break that
door down for you to finally go fine i'm
gonna let you in
okay so for me but so i am what they
call
empathic and i didn't understand this at
the time i
feel people's energy so especially when
i start to connect with a soul
they'll make me feel the bond that they
shared with someone but then they'll
make me feel how they died
so if they die tragically i'll taste
blood sometimes it's all like if someone
had an aneurysm or they had a bleed out
um if they couldn't communicate if they
had a tube down their throat i'll feel
like someone's restricting my throat
and it's just for like a split second
but i've learned to understand what that
was so imagine feeling all of those
things and not knowing what it was
and i was afraid of everything i
couldn't leave my house at this point
and when my mom had suggested uh
for me to go to the spiritual awareness
class it was always on wednesday nights
and i was deathly afraid of
pouring rain i could not drive in a car
if it was pouring rain
actually when i went into labor with my
daughter i was literally pacing my
driveway in the
in the pouring rain with my doctor going
i can't come to the hospital
it's rush hour there's going to be
traffic and it's pouring rain out and
he's like and and i'm like and i cannot
get in the car
but i think it was because it was a past
life that i had i don't know if you're
familiar with past life regressions
totally i'm past life akash records
reincarnation
we can go any direction you want to go
perfect so i had done uh past life
regressions many times and one of them
was that i
was a captive on a boat and we were and
i died in
a horrible storm on the boat and it was
pouring rain and the water was crashing
over
and it was very very intense so i feel
that where that comes from now i
i'm fine i'm over that because when i
decided to go to these classes
wouldn't you know every wednesday night
it was
torrential downpour rain and this went
on
for about six weeks so finally the woman
that does the class
she said listen she says you're just and
she only lived across town it wasn't
like i had to go far it was literally
like
10 minutes from my house and i would
i took baby steps i literally would go
out and practice in the pouring rain
backing out of the driveway just driving
down the block
i'd go to the store up the block so i
took like these baby steps
for me working through my anxieties and
my fears
and having to grow my soul i always
found a way to give myself options so
for me as long as i gave myself an
option
even if it was unrealistic i felt
rationally it was an option so i could
go ahead and do this
so um like i terrible fear of elevators
you know i mean the crazy thing is can
we just talk about for a second i
couldn't even leave my house now i
tour the country and i live on a tour
bus for god's sakes
right and i i'm alone i'm using these
like these space doors that have to
close by using air compression that i'm
like
we've got to leave all the doors open on
the tour bus and my crew is like
you can't leave the doors open i'm like
oh watch me we're leaving the doors open
the lights are on
i lived on a bus too when i raced i mean
we lived on buses yeah we lived on
basically
yeah you know these super hot super high
end nice you know
fancy buses with slide outs and flat
screens and
all of it you know far from glamorous
but
i i love it i enjoy it it it it brings
me back to my days of going camping with
my grandparents
i was spending summers uh camping so
like i'm just wondering like how did
that go you know so you go camping and
you're with your grandparents and you're
sitting by the campfire
and you're just like seeing stuff
feeling stuff
what's like it's coming through it's
been coming through
your whole life right so it didn't it
didn't go
well i can tell you that did you say
anything were you ever like
so hey grandma um so there's a guy
you know never mind literally exactly
i'd be like did you see that woman walk
by or i would feel like there would be
like a bear's gonna attack i mean so you
have to remember this is back in the 70s
my grandparents had a trailer
so we were like oh wow you guys have a
trailer you know when we had a shower
and bunk beds my grandmother had a
kitchen i mean back in the 70s that was
unheard of right
and when my parents would cause we would
go i would go with my grandparents and
we would stay for like a couple of weeks
and when my parents would come up i'd
sleep in the tent with my parents
and i was so afraid that we were gonna
get stuck in the tent and i would wake
up with these blood-curdling screams
trying to you would think someone was
literally getting murdered in our tent
and i was trying to get out i knocked
over the lantern
i think i gave my dad a fat lip my dad's
like we're never doing camping again
what happened it was just they finally
calmed me down i was so i was so afraid
that we were going to get stuck in a
tent
and i like had this crazy i mean i was
little i was like maybe
nine and you were scared so you're just
so
serious all the all the things that you
were feeling
and so you kind of see things do you
hear things or is it more of like a
knowing yes it's more of a knowing
i guess to explain it to someone i feel
like i'm hearing something but i'm
really
not hearing a voice because i can hear
someone quote-unquote speak to me in a
different language
i really don't know what they're it's
it's a knowing it's a feeling that i get
that i know that it's different
it's such a fascinating world and
there's so many people that this is like
beyond the scope of their imagination so
i'm so curious
because you've been in this world like
why don't
what is the what is the dissonance why
can't people
why don't people believe in spirit realm
well i think um it's scary it's it's
hard for us to believe
in something that we can't physically
see right
think about it right i think that's one
of the things why people struggle with
a higher power god yahweh buddha
however you want to interpret it a
faith but they have a hard time grasping
things that they can't physically see
and not knowing and you know i always
said i don't know how this works
it just all of a sudden when spirit
starts communicating i have no
activity in my brain it's like my mind
goes blank
i only have thoughts feelings and
emotions of who's
channeling or who i'm speaking to and i
actually did something
live on the dr oz show and we also did
it on long island medium
where dr ehman studied my brain
as i read someone and he said to me says
you're able to access a part of your
brain that
people typically don't and my he goes
when you were channeling your
brain it like literally flatlined like
there was no activity but you were
speaking
i don't have an explanation for it and
i don't the thing that gets me sometimes
danica it's like
why does someone fight something if it's
helping someone
yeah yeah and i struggled with my gift
for over five years you know we talked
about me trying to get
to these classes and it poured rain
every wednesday night
for five years it took me to really
accept
and embrace my gift and what i learned
was that because i couldn't understand
like okay i'm blessed with this gift
who's going to want to come and see a
medium who wants to talk to that
everyone i love it i i didn't understand
that at that time
yeah and what i learned was that
unfortunately no matter who we lose
how they die we here in the physical
world are left with burdens and guilts
i should have could have would have yeah
maybe an only and
and only if and at the end of the day if
you have a negative emotion
attached to someone that passed how can
you heal
you're gonna grieve but you're how can
you heal if you're beating yourself up
with all of these negative emotions
desire desire hooking into those sort of
um stories keep the spirit close
what do you mean if you have like a
certain a strong emotion around someone
and something that happened does the
spirit want to come
come through more so to to help heal
that
yes i find what do they want to say
too like what's their purpose normally
so for example and i don't know if this
is
what i'm this is what i felt as you
asked me this question so i always feel
like when i talk about my gift it's
always
guided by spirit maybe there's someone
on this call maybe it's for someone
listening
right now that will find healing in this
what i
saw was a young male step forward and
he showed me my symbol for where he
wanted to take responsibility for his
departure
i did taste something and i saw a
medicine bottle
that's my symbol for where they took
something or mixed medications without
knowing
that caused or attributed to their
departure i find
that a lot of times souls that leave the
physical world tragically unexpected
they tend to step forward more so okay
because we then beat ourselves up with
maybe a survivor's guilt
whatever it may be you know when we also
tend to what i also realize is that we
tend to the things that we experience we
think everyone
has experienced it and it just isn't so
what do you mean you know like like if
if i say to someone i mean like my
grandparents
were like my parents i my grandparents
passed when i was well in my 40s
so i was very blessed to have my
grandparents and
if a grandparent steps forward people oh
of course their grandparents died
but you don't understand that fun and
not everyone loses their grandparents
i read people that they're in their 20s
and they lost their their father or they
lost their mom
at a very young age and not everyone
suffers
loss and especially at a young age
and especially and i i believe that part
of the reason why i haven't suffered so
much loss
or tragedy for that fact is because
i was able to explore my gift with no
opinion
[Music]
you know because people say that all the
time oh well you could google you could
listen if people think i got time to
google stuff about people
and the things that spirit talks about
there's you
can't find that you can't google that
and it's actually harder for me
to read someone if i know something
about them that's why i always say my
own family gets screwed out of messages
from their own loved ones because
i i think if i start sensing my life i
was like oh am i
remembering that is that something that
i knew that's something that they told
me
so you start second guessing it
[Music]
so i really believe that was also
part of my soul's journey not to really
suffer so much
loss and tragedy
so i could learn and understand my gift
what was happening my signs my symbols
so you could be more clear without so
much trauma or so much sadness or pain
right or an experience
oh i get it so that you are more of a
clean slate for
the information coming through because
you haven't you're not sort of rooted in
so many
like traumatic experiences that would
sort of sway your perspective
correct your lens it brings me back to
when i wrote uh
one of my books called good grief and
when i was sitting with
um my i call him my spirit writer
because i don't like to use ghost
ghost is so scary
i said i want to write about the stages
of grief
and uh she said okay and i i was jumping
all over and saying wait wait wait we
got to go another i said who said
who says we have to go in order and she
looked at me and she says oh you're
right and i said that's how i want the
book to be i want this to be a book for
people that can say okay
i i might not feel this grief it doesn't
mean that i'm not grieving my loved ones
like i feel like there's no right or
wrong way
who says that there's a right or wrong
way to grieve someone
yeah there isn't and you might feel
those stages of grief and you might not
and and i think that we place i think at
the end of the day especially through
this whole pandemic i i've learned we
put
so much pressure on ourselves and we
worry about things that we don't have
control over
or that we can't change
some people say to me they're like but
why do you think you know you think so
um simple and i'm like but
is there anything wrong with that does
life have to be
that difficult i listened to abraham do
you ever listen to abraham hicks or
heard of abraham hicks
no i've heard of the name okay like she
channels
source energy and like a different form
of communication
and so but still accessing the quantum
and the energy coming through and i was
just listening to
uh there's like lots of 15 minute little
videos on youtube and it's like
you all make so much of a big deal about
this it's just not that big of a deal
right does spirit want to say that the
spirit of spirit trying to
say that they have they because it's
almost like i've used the term over and
over where they say
you've made a mountain out of a molehill
it could
i'll put it in in in kind of simple
terms it's like
what if you're on the line at the
grocery store think about it
so i used to find myself getting
aggravated
if the person took too long in front of
me think about it right you get
you get all worked up like i got things
to do why they taking so long
what's the matter with their credit card
what do you mean they didn't have enough
money
oh didn't they know that that wasn't on
sale they're looking for that coupon
i mean we've all done it at some time
right no yeah
like every day and we work ourselves up
right and we work ourselves up and it's
like
all right so when i leave the house if
i'm pressed for time i sometimes don't
go or i just pick
two things that i that i can do and i
just roll with it and i'm like you know
what
something there's a different plan for
me here today
so then does spirit see because i think
one of the things you were talking about
grief and i feel like
when people pass people have such a
difficult time with the transition and
part of it i think has to do with not
wanting to disrespect the situation
that has passed and that they will
somehow know
or feel offended if they laugh or if
they smile or if they find a new partner
and i'm wondering what's what spirit
wants to say
about the moving on process for someone
that's closely
intimately or closely associated with
that person sure so
i'll use this as an example there are
times many times spirit has come through
and said
my wife won't move on if she get if
someone dies
oh she'll go to their wake or funeral
but god forbid she get an invitation to
go to a wedding or to someone's birthday
party she won't go
he goes it's the same i remember a soul
coming through and saying it's the same
thing
you go to someone's wake you're talking
about that person's life
you're remembering them we are laughing
and we are crying right
but a lot of times when we find
ourselves reminiscing and
and feeling happy of the things that the
person accomplished
it's the same thing for a wedding or a
birthday party
right you're celebrating somebody's life
some somebody's accomplishments
and again it's what we do to ourselves
time and time again especially now with
kovid souls have said to me over the
years
what we do with our physical body is for
us
not them because they're not a part of
the physical body anymore
so because some people that they would
show me a symbol of um
they would show me a headstone i'd be
dressed in a three-piece suit
they would spin me around and have me
come out in like jeans and a t-shirt and
then they would
tie my hands together like handcuff my
hands together
that's my symbol for where someone was
having a difficult time on the way that
someone was laid to rest
sometimes it's some people maybe they
didn't want to cremate their loved ones
but financially their hands were tied
they had no choice
or that was their wishes but they wanted
something else
and they will say it time and time again
we are not part of that physical body
don't remember a sick suffering with any
ailments and the way that you
and they spirit feels the way that we
remember them
every day in our life like um
say if your loved one loved pizza and
it's their birthday you went out you had
pizza
and ice cream like they love the things
that they love to do or that you did
together and when you do those things
they love that the most has spirit ever
wanted
someone to uh like have they ever had
any contrasting sort of
hopes for someone in the human realm
that couldn't let go like yeah i want
them to keep thinking about me or do
they
do they always want to say move on or is
it that they just don't
care because they're not in that human
form anymore
and that's just not part of the
connection
well we will always think of our loved
ones we will always remember them moving
on
uh safe i'll use the example if someone
loses a spouse
if they find a companion usually spirit
will say they found a company someone
just to
enjoy the rest of your life with that
doesn't mean that you're forgetting
about me
it's the same thing if we let go of
negative emotions or negative
things that have happened maybe it's the
way we remember when they died or we
were trying to revive them
and we're left with that memory just
because we let go of that
doesn't mean that we forget them they
just want us to let go of the things
that aren't helping us heal
at the end of the day we're gonna grieve
the loss of our loved ones for the rest
of our lives here in the physical world
the healing process is something
completely different
it's the same thing with even just
people with relationships here in the
physical world
right we get hurt over and over
through friendships maybe marriages
whatever they are we're hurt right
but we heal we have to grieve that
i i still i still talk about this i'm
i'm divorced
i'm i still grieve my marriage i
probably will for the rest of my life
but i'm healing from it and
there's nothing wrong with that i feel
that's so healthy because
grief doesn't always have to be negative
why can't
grief be a good thing i mean that's a
beautiful reframe because you can look
at it much more from the perspective of
like
as you go through grief it implies
healing there's always a con
there's always the balance right yeah
you know yeah look we can remain
broken you can do that but why
are you going to ruin the rest of your
life here for something that you didn't
have control over
it's so unfair and even if you did make
choices that changed your life path
forgive forgiveness is well i think one
of the hardest things people struggle
with is forgiveness
and it's so important and it's not about
forgiving other people
it's almost like forgiving yourself to
forgive them in a sense
just so you can move on have you had um
anything in the realm of forgiveness or
anything that has come to you um
as far as lessons go that were really
hard for you to
move on from oh my god oh sure
you know um i mean i think
i've talked about this recently about
soul searching
i think that is one of the hardest
things someone has to really do is to
take a look at themselves
take a look at their soul and decide
how we want to improve that or have that
grow
i think um i remember talking to someone
and they were telling me they're like
what's wrong with me why can't i ever
find a boyfriend or have someone like
who says anything wrong with you
right who says it's you you know if
you know and i find especially today
women's roles have changed i shouldn't
say change all we did is add
to our roles you know think about it
years ago right we we
took care of the house right we cooked
we cleaned we nurtured our family
we're still doing all that but we're
also
cur we have our careers we just keep
adding to it
right and we become these strong
powerful independent women
and a lot of times i think men have a
hard time with that
do you think that there's i i literally
i was talking to somebody just the other
day
and she was talking about some things
that have happened in her life and
i sort of flippantly said the
matriarchal
you know era is here do you feel that i
don't know i've been surrounded by
there's been so many strong females
and and the thing the words that she
wrote were
that made me think of that where she
said i feel so strong
and so soft but i think that's what
makes us so
unique and how we can be i think we have
to be soft to be strong
does that make sense well someone
actually recently
defined strong and powerful to me as
not doing getting controlling
not that yeah right love she said
your strength and power is love
oh control is not one of the things that
should be in anyone's
path like i don't have any control when
spirit communicates
i have no idea what's going to happen
that's why so many
times and time again i'll use for
example on this season of long island
meeting with meghan trainor
she and her husband reading them all of
a sudden someone comes through and it
was for her
manager she was not expecting to be
on camera was not looking for a reading
it wasn't up to me
and i think i i think we all try to
quote unquote control
things but i've learned through my gift
that
i have no control over what happens this
honestly
what i do danica has nothing to do with
me
i am just the vessel that spirit uses
to get their messages through and to
surrender that
control is um was very difficult it was
hard i had to kind of
i kind of put it in spirits and says
okay this is it this is what i'm
supposed to do you
open these doors i will gladly walk
through every door
even my kids don't you think i mean
don't you think that my kids
first of all i have really good kids i
think people always think that they have
good kids
but um they i always
just am there to support them i will
give them my advice
of course and my guidance as a parent
but never
ever control or demand something from
them
it's always supportive and allowing them
to make their own choices
it's their free will choices do you
think that this
i'm kind of curious do you think that
this is a movement
happening in the sort of the spirit of
what you just said
is something that's becoming more
prevalent in the world and is this what
we need
obviously we have like chaos right like
it's crazy and control is
out of control and the in the worst way
and narcissism is just so rampant and
um you know greed and follow the money
and it's just
you know it's like do you feel that
there's a shift happening
and is it going to be because of like
the attitude and um embodiment that
you're describing that you have for your
kids let's say
i hope so i mean i
i've said this for years and this is how
i was raised
i don't have to like someone or
something
but i have to respect it people have to
learn
how to agree to disagree
and think about it when we have
uncomfortable conversations whether that
with your children
partner maybe about the world whatever
it is when something is uncomfortable
it promotes change think about it right
and people are so afraid people don't
want to be uncomfortable
i know i know and i i kind of embrace
that i kind of like when i'm like all
right what
i find yeah because i know something
amazing is gonna happen it's like all
right wait i'm gonna learn something
or maybe something's gonna get validated
but that's why it's so important to just
be
open where'd you get that from though
where did you get that from because this
is the thing is like
i i mean like that is what everyone
would hope to embody is this you know is
that as that
attitude where did you get that from did
you learn it i got that from my parents
from my parents and uh and i'm gonna say
this it even goes back to my great great
uh it goes back to my great grandmother
when they came over from italy
um and i'm it's gonna tie in so this is
the right i'm telling you this
um they she drove my great-grandmother
drove
women did not drive in the in the right
in the
30s right she drove they owned a
restaurant
um didn't have much uh but
um and my uncle was uh actually bullied
at school
uh because he spoke funny he spoke
italian they they came from italy
so my grandmother tells the story that
my great-grandmother
she forbidded them to speak italian in
the house they could only speak english
and she said you have to respect
everyone and we we have we're going to
only speak english in the house
so my grandmother could understand it
but then she couldn't speak it
um so i and i think um it was just the
way i was raised
and how i was surrounded that truly
we're all the same
and we have to respect people i and my i
i remember my mom my great grandmother
by the way she was the first
soul that i had seen i i remember when i
was in my 20s seeing an old picture of
my great-grandmother and i said to my
grandmother graham
who's this picture of this woman and
she's like that's my mom
how did you not know that this is that
your great-grandmother i'm like
i'm just realizing that she was the
woman that would stand at the end of my
bed at night
and watch over me oh my god
it's just it's so crazy and
you know i don't believe in i don't
think there's such things as coincidence
i think
things happen for a reason i believe
people are placed in our path for a
reason
maybe it's for a moment maybe it's for a
lifetime maybe it's for a period of time
but they're placed in our path for a
reason
and it's up to us whether we choose to
learn and to grow
and sometimes have to move on i mean
that's hard
i mean i wrote about in my i think
there's something
um i i just put out a book in october
called
good morning m-o-u-r-n-i-n-g
and um i was pushed to write this book
over two years ago from spirit
about how we grieve every day of our
life not just when we lose a loved one
and the book was always scheduled to be
released in october of 2020
not knowing that we were going to hit
this pandemic and the book had already
been finished prior to the pandemic
and every chapter is something it's
about loss of a friend
loss of an argument loss of youth loss
of um
how we feel after retirement all these
things that
did you ever think of that about how we
really we grieve an argument
how we grieve friendships and
the reason why grief hits us so hard
is because we allow we don't acknowledge
all of these things that we've lost a
loss is a loss
it's something that we don't have what
once was
and we no longer have it and we grieve
it
whether it be finance as a house a job
relationship yeah but then when we lose
a loved one it's like
all of this comes it hits us all at once
then we start going over
everything and beating ourselves up
that's why
i believe sometimes when we lose a loved
one the grief hits us the most
i i don't know what it is i am so
distracted by your necklace
i don't know what this what what your
necklace is oh
um is that leprade or what is this lapis
i can't
see it it almost looks like black onyx
and i'm like i don't
i am so necklace
okay so um i'm uh i'm
i've been wanting to go to egypt for so
long and i'm leaving in a few days
i am i'm leaving in a few days and
i've had so much come around the
uh goddess isis
actually this is an isis ring um
and i bought it years ago and i have no
idea why i bought it like i was like
i was like that's what happens i i
collect things into my
reality and then later i'm like oh well
that makes sense
i have um the girl leading the retreat
is isis um
i met this lady who wrote a book called
the sofia code and her first
key code is isis and i read it and i got
oh maybe this is something you could
tell me so
i had um i i'll say the lapis thing
first and then i'll ask the next
question because then you'll be able to
go on
but um isis's um stone is lapis and
years and years like six seven years ago
in sedona
i was told my stone was lapis oh my god
that's the first time i ever
saw lapis was in sedona i was at a
crystal fair
yeah so anyway so i read this key code
and i was i i had met her and had dinner
with the writer and
um the author and she so she channeled
in this information she said at the
beginning of each
uh key code is um is a direct account
from the goddess of what it was like to
be a human and then there's initiations
and key codes that you read out loud to
access um more of your genome
your dna access more codes and so
um so i read the like i got home from
dinner like really late read like
the eight page sort of synopsis from
isis of what it was like to be a human
and then i got i put the book by the bed
and i
i went turn the light off and then i was
like in a hoodie sweatshirt
sweatpants and i was so cold
i put three blankets on top of me i was
freezing i never got hot once in the
night i was to the bone
cold i was like i was literally like
i've never
had so many layers and slept and been so
cold
and so i mean a couple people have sort
of told me what they think it is but
that's spirit
it's the souls yeah that's why because
when you are so
cold like that it's almost like there
are times
i can almost feel like i can see my
breath
but i can't but that's how i feel and
it's this coldness that
you've never felt before it's not like
it's a different
cold no one will understand that but one
of my past
lives was i was buried alive with
the king in egypt oh my god well of
course we're talking
i have a lot of egyptian history there's
a lot of stories
people have told me stories about being
in egypt 5 000 years ago
through um shamans and then i've heard
it through
other like through you know stories from
other people that have seen me in egypt
like oh my god
so i'm going for two weeks oh i am so
jealous
that's i'd be probably petrified to do
something like that
i don't know i you know spirit
so much so much so much so heavy
so much so very curious about that are
there can you
you so you can feel areas where there's
more
uh energetic density what do you feel
what do you feel
i notice people will notice it around me
it's like something changes inside of me
sometimes my personality changes a
little bit like when i'm in
in new orleans
first time i was there i was fine i was
standing on a street corner you can see
this beam of
light coming like right through me and i
felt like it was protection
and i was fine went back another time i
was actually pushed during a live show
by a soul and one of my cam the stuff
was flying off of their cameras the
lights the batteries
oh yeah like right in front of thousands
of people i you can't even make this up
my so that's light that was flickering
around
no on on their cameras so when i do my
live shows
i don't stay on the stage i get down in
the crowd spirit guides me around the
space
and we have camera i have two cameramen
that follow me around the theater
and it's displayed on a camera so no
matter where you're seated you get to be
a part of the experience
one of my cameramen that was with me
standing beside me
so they have like a diva light i don't
know i don't know if that yeah
whatever that is um right here there you
go
that's a deal that's it
so on cameras they they get hooked on
and then their batteries get hooked onto
the back of the camera
flying off of the cameras how were they
getting how are they falling off the
cameras
it was like energy it was energy it was
energy
and it was something going on in those
theaters down there
i mean and he tripped and i'm like you
were pushed i watched it and he's like i
didn't push i tripped i'm like there was
nothing for you to trip on like
he was like so fighting that that spirit
was doing this and i'm like no i'm
telling you they're just
they're just messing with us oh my god i
had a crazy experience one time
like speaking of like just seeing
something happen
and not understanding it it was back
when i first got my dog dallas
and she was running away from me and i
she was by a road and she was taking off
towards the road
and she went through a ditch and as she
ran through the ditch
something pulled over i just saw that
pulled it
off and she barrel rolled and just after
she did that a car went by
and i was like that was
not normal like there's no i couldn't
even pull her collar off but it yanked
her collar so hard to pull her so she
wouldn't keep running
so what's happening is that just so to
me that's
spirit has always said to me our destiny
in life is set
how we get there is up to the free will
choices that we make
so we have a block of time so
this is what spirit has set it to um
when people especially get in a car
accident and the car is totally wrecked
and they walk away without a scratch
they were not supposed to be
there at that time it wasn't their
soul's time some people
might get involved with a then live
their life in a coma
maybe paralyzed i know of someone
that uh tried to take his own life
several times and didn't succeed and
ended up living his life in a wheelchair
for 15 years because it wasn't his
soul's time to leave the physical world
so this is like the butting heads of
like your soul's purpose
and your free will yeah mm-hmm
so okay so you can but you could end
your life could end before your block of
time
or can it not from what spirit has
showed me that we have this block of
time i don't know if the block of time
is years days hours but there's a block
of time
where we can exit some of us
live when we get like really quick
unexpected departures
that's usually when we live to the end
of our block of time
sometimes peop and especially with
people that try to
do things to end their life and they
don't succeed it's because it wasn't
their soul's time to leave the physical
world
but i think that's one of the hardest
things that i've had to uh
deliver a message especially to a parent
because parents aren't supposed to bury
their children
whether they're diagnosed with cancer
um and you know
i don't i don't know why i'm seeing this
but i always say things happen for a
reason
if you don't mind me sharing this story
uh maybe this will un
people can maybe under it's very deep
it's a very deep
statement and something that we were
talking about that i don't know if most
people will
understand and it's much more than just
a block of time i remember years ago
it was on long island medium years ago a
um
couple had walked in my home and i sense
things
when someone walks in my home
couple walks in and i'm like oh she
does not like him she is unhappy with
him and i didn't know at the time who
they were
come walking and they sit down husband
and wife
their son comes through he had down
syndrome
uh his name was shane and uh
shane came through and said please tell
my mom
that it wasn't daddy's fault that i died
whoa i i mean you maybe can even see the
goose bumps i've
realized that i'm starting to get more
in touch with my body and goosebumps or
yes there is a yes absolutely
and the story goes the mom never left
shane's side
and she decided this one saturday to go
to her daughter's dance recital and left
shane home with his dad
his dad was on the phone shane got out
of the sliding door
and drown in the family pool
and shane i just got the chills big time
and shane
said mom how many times did i get out of
the sliding glass door
when you were home daddy's soul
it was his journey to carry the burden
of my death not you
because you never would have been able
to live
if i died on your watch
yeah and i get a christmas card from
this family
i'm i'm crying just thinking about it
that uh the family is still together at
that moment i watched her
reach over the table and hold her
husband's hand
and i think for me at that moment that
reading was
what i do is so much more than just
channeling the souls of the departed
it reunites families how many people
they don't speak they're not speaking to
each other for whatever reason and
someone comes for a reading and then the
family gets reunited because they reach
out because of the experience
uh but that is one of the stories that i
feel is
one of the most heartbreaking and
uh but the most healing and for people
to understand i mean that boy got out
how many times time and time again and
he
he was young i think he was like four or
six he was very young
so sometimes sometimes so people have so
that's the soul's mission
yeah this is this is your
this is your cross to bear this is your
this is your
and is there something beyond that is
there a lesson to learn in it
oh i'm sure there were a bunch of
lessons for his soul
to learn they say that our soul this is
a big school right now what we're
in right we can learn reincarnation i
want to talk about i'm very curious i'm
very curious yes
i mean with having past life regressions
then you then
obviously that implies in reincarnation
so um
so i have you ever heard of dolores
cannon no
i am probably the most sheltered person
you will ever she's dead but she was a
hypno therapist oh
and she would um she realized that she
was going deeper into the
subconscious than anyone um and so
she learned a lot but one of the things
that she would always say
is is that if you don't learn the
lessons in this
life then you come back the next to
learn it so you might as well learn it
here you might as well
get on with it mm-hmm yeah that is that
how
i and is that true that's look
whether you're understanding to my
understanding i the things that i speak
about danica are things of my own
personal experience
in life and also with the souls of the
departed what they've shown me what
they've made me feel what they've told
me what they've told my clients
i remember doing a past life regression
and i was told by my spirit guide that
this was my soul's last journey here in
the physical world
wow yeah i mean that sounds i mean to me
i hear relief
is that it's a lot i i try not to think
about that
you know because when you when you it's
so this feels heavy i mean this this has
a waste
what is it about it that feels heavy
well
you know it's still i still go through
okay so what am i going to do like
what's going to happen if i'm not going
to come back if my soul's not going to
learn any any more lessons like what is
going to happen
so it's almost then i'll be like a a
guide
what form of spirit guide i don't know
because there are spirit guides that
never have walked here in the physical
world they're just souls that have never
walked and then
there are others that watch over um i
always say i'll find out when i get
there
right it's like i always say too i'm
like i really want to know what it's
like what's
what's reality and what's exciting but
i'm gonna have to die to figure out i'm
not ready
yeah exactly listen i i don't want to
die
but i know i'm not afraid to die anymore
i think we all especially as children we
we were afraid of death right because
again it's something that we don't know
what's gonna happen are we gonna miss
our parents
are we gonna miss our friends what are
we are we gonna be crying because we
can't
touch them and from what spirit has
shown me we're the ones that suffer
they're still with us just in a
different way they're living life
through our eyes
that's why the healing is so important
because they don't want to live their
life through our eyes
feeling sad and sorrow they want you to
live with happiness and joy that's why i
love when spirit comes through when they
talk about the things that we do
that we've done since they've died to
say oh okay they're not missing out
yeah to orient your perspective on the
positives
so i'm curious though with reincarnation
um
so if you're speaking to a soul so like
i would have this opinion
in my right now that you know this
that your soul reincarnates to continue
its soul's evolution to
its final stage of self-actualization
total embodiment of spirit of source
self
um and becoming whole and transitioning
to another dimension or frequency that
isn't this density um so
but i'm curious if if this happens a lot
like i'm imagining that we probably do
this thousands of times
um so if somebody's passed let's say for
i knew you were going to ask this a long
time
but they're still coming through i'm
curious i'm just i'm confused how they
still come through
and well no no well so here so here
here's the story that i can use to
maybe help clarify this for you okay
spirit has told me that
when we re-enter is when our soul circle
is complete
when the souls are gonna re-enter so
like i've done a past life before where
i was a young man and i there was a
house burning and i was searching for
someone
and the person conducting the past life
said okay you found your brother
look in his eyes and tell me who you see
i saw my nephew
i saw my sons my brother's son
so my my nephew was my brother in a
previous life
because the eyes is the gateway to the
soul so she had me look in the eyes and
it was my nephew
and so now i'm gonna explain this i was
doing a reading it was a mother
and a daughter and the mother
had lost a daughter as the daughter was
channeling she's having me speak to her
sister and saying you used to see me all
the time
but it was weird it was like i i would
say to her
you used to see your sister it wasn't
like i was just i was making statements
to her
i wasn't like saying your sister is
saying i was saying you used to see your
sister anymore but you don't see her
anymore
but you look in your daughter's eyes and
ever since your daughter was born
you don't see your sister anymore and
she said yes i said well because
your sister's soul is your daughter
that was the one and only time
that that had ever happened wow
yeah i mean that's what i mean dolores
cannon would say that too she's like
she's like this doesn't work out in this
life and you know you
the next life i'll be the husband did
you be the wife and we're going to
switch positions and we're going to
we're going to try it again yeah yeah so
that's what they
do and oh wow that's insane so that was
that was the one and only time that that
had happened um where
someone had where the soul was here and
then re-entered right away
so uh sometimes with babies they'll say
um i gave my soul so my sister could
come here in the physical
world uh there are things like that that
have happened
um i don't know why i don't have the
answer
and i don't think it's something that we
hear in the physical world
can figure out i think that is something
that we
only know in the spirit realm
and that is mentioned ever has ever like
talked about or sort of given you the
information or awareness to what we're
supposed to be doing here
we're supposed to be we're supposed to
be learning lessons we're supposed to be
loving each other we're supposed to all
be
on kind of the same page but we have to
have that ying and the yang
you know we're always going to have
differences but
we're supposed to be learning the
lessons so the soul can grow
in a positive and strong way to really
kind of get rid of
those scars because it's harder to learn
lessons here in the physical world than
it is on the other side
my interpretation of that is because for
example
i've noticed it with fathers what will
say to their children
i'm sorry that i didn't understand you
i'm sorry that i didn't support you i am
proud of the man that you've become
so sometimes that's when um
hypothetically if they wanted to be a
gym teacher and the father wanted them
to be an attorney
or maybe um they were gay
and the father didn't understand that
couldn't accept that but then
the soul has to relive their life
through their loved ones eyes that they
hurt or disappointed or didn't support
so they had to
feel what it was like to be them
to be treated like that
they had to for the soul and that at
that frequency can feel negativity
yes well they would feel they would feel
what it was like for that person
with their actions caused someone else
okay so my symbol for that is sometimes
they'll show me like a
child sitting on a street corner and
then the sun going down that's my symbol
for where a parent
disappointed their child again that's
for the person to
interpret not for me to understand
whatever it may be
and that the soul had to relive
their life through their child's eyes
to feel what it was like
switch positions i'm curious if it's
true that we choose our
we choose our our parents and we choose
sort of our
lessons in the life or scenarios
the players right is that true or to
your understanding
from what from my understanding for yes
wow that's right because think about it
man think about like the parents that
you pick coming in and the cri like
i mean i just literally like i'm being
honest i just had like a moment
the other day where i was accepting this
dynamic of me as a 10 year old with the
way that my parents are
and you know i had a big big big release
and i was like
you know you know i i picked these
lessons i picked these parents and
they're wonderful but it doesn't mean
that they don't all come with lessons
so i guess that's the thing and and
that's that they all do
right they have to that's the point of
your soul's reason for being here is the
lesson so don't be mad when you get one
just freaking man up woman up and solve
it
but it's not only your lessons but it's
also their lessons as well
so it's not just so narrow in your
lessons
so it has to do with their lessons i
feel that
we do the best that we can at that time
with what information think about it
back then when you were saying 10
right things were very different that
and i think that that's why
we beat ourselves up where things are so
hard sometimes because
we look back on a situation whatever it
may be
and we beat ourselves up there shoulda
coulda would have only but that's unfair
you're not putting yourself back there
in that emotional state
right how you are now is very different
how you were
what 20 30 years ago and sometimes we
have to accept there are sometimes
that i look back on my life and i say
you know what that was really immature
of me to
do that or to feel that way or to think
that way right
but isn't that the last thing that's the
the lesson that is the point though it's
not supposed lessons aren't supposed to
be easy
no but how many people say
i was wrong i
was wrong i was how many people very
very small
oh i'm the first one oh i messed that up
i screwed that up oh my god
i don't know what i'm doing um
but that's that's hard a lot of people
have a hard time because they look at it
as
failure and for me when i look back on a
choice
i don't like to say mistake i like to
look at it as a choice and
realize that i would make a different
choice
i look at that as a lesson learned and
that is my
soul growing and how i grew experience i
don't look at it
as a mistake or that i was wrong
do you feel like that i learned
something yeah which is
so beautiful and so important and again
it's all about perspective so reframing
or framing things in a way that is
positive and productive is there um
given the fact that this is your last
incarnation
um before you become a beautiful angelic
guide
um or whatever it is that you become a
demi demigod or
whatever you know back to source energy
is there uh
is there a lesson that you're like i
know that i
probably need to learn this one before i
go
um i think loving unconditionally my
interpretation of that for myself is
that really
accepting and honoring people for who
and what they are
and still um respecting them at the same
breath even though i
don't might not agree with them i think
that's something that
um i continue to work on
except situations whatever they may be
and just
try to look at things with such a loving
um attitude
i mean especially come on i mean this
past year has tough
we've all lost something maybe it might
not have been someone but we lost
something maybe a part of ourselves
i feel like i've lost a whole year
people ask me i'm like oh yeah that was
last year and i'm like uh
wait a minute teresa that was two years
ago that was three years ago because i
feel
like the whole year didn't happen so we
all lost something
yeah and it might not have been someone
but we've all changed and
things just aren't the same and we can
either choose to just
wallow in that or we can just pick up
and say okay you know what things gonna
be but i'm excited to see what this new
normal is going to be
yeah yeah me too i think that there's
such a um i said i think there's such a
direction towards
energy and um
feelings and emotions and um a
thinning of the veil of everything from
energy to transparency of person like i
just think it's thinning
and so i and timelines to me seem so
accelerated like
you think something it happens or you
know just things are being dissolved and
created and it just seems really crazy
fast and so
it feels like a time where if you wanted
to
get more in touch with this sort of
spiritual
spirit aspect of you or energy or
frequency or the quantum field
that perhaps you'd have your best chance
ever to really um
cultivate that as quickly as possible so
is there something
i believe that does everyone have the
ability to speak to spirit
and feel that energy yes i believe
everyone can connect with their own
loved ones that have died
i believe that and know that beautiful
so what would you say to people if they
wanted to that would be some things that
they could do
to start to cultivate that um awareness
to the signs to the voices to
the synchronicities um to that energy
my first thing to people is just pay
attention just be
open to what goes on around anything
that reminds you
of your loved one i don't care what it
is
and you think of them at that moment
know that that's them with you at this
moment and you're not alone
i think that's the biggest thing don't
say up
mom i know it's you if i see four red
cardinals by sunday
you can't do that it's like then once
you start to get that then like take
baby steps
if you have a hard time meditating just
take it to a minute
a day just concentrating on your
breathing for one minute
then try three minutes that's what i did
my mind is always full of chatter and i
i worked up and i don't put so much
pressure on with it some people can
meditate for hours
i can only do 10 minutes at a time
that's what works for me
i think we put pressure and we think
things connecting with our loved ones
has to be this or it should be this or
it should feel like this
it's a simple thing of sometimes i smell
cigarette smoke i know it's my my dad's
mom
i know it's her uh sometimes i smell my
my grandfather's cologne i know he's
with me i smell gardenias i know my
grandmother is with me for a split
second
thank you very much for sharing so much
about your experience
and you know i just think there's such a
level of bravery to it because
it's not only is it different
although i think people are getting used
to it but also
there's a level of trust with yourself
about the energy and it's so great that
you've allowed yourself to cultivate
that
that trust within yourself to get that
information out
and you know when we talked on our when
we talked for your show
um i was it was so beautiful for me to
be able to
talk to my mom about her mom coming
through and also dale jr
as dale senior came through and dale jr
was just honestly he was taken
that day his he put his daughter in like
old throwback t-shirts like there was a
lot of things that had happened
right then and he had post a bunch of
throwback pictures on his social media
and so the fact that he came through was
like really meaningful to him and his
wife sent me a message and so
you know this work is really really
meaningful and beautiful and so thank
you for
sharing your gift and and saying yes
like to saying yes to your soul's
purpose
and that's why that's why you won't have
to do being human again because it's
hard to be human it is it is well thank
you
i do consider it such an honor thank you
for allowing me to share my gift
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today
i hope you enjoyed it if you like what
you heard today and you want to hear
more please click
on the subscribe button